I'm joined today by vivica Novak who is
an investigative editor for McClatchy
cheese Washington bureau she's been a
journalist in Washington DC for more
than 20 years vivica it's so great to
talk to you you have been following what
appears to be a sort of funding funnel
from Russia through the NRA and to
Donald Trump how was this even something
that initially got on your radar well we
had been hearing actually for quite some
time that this may have been happening
and it took us months and months to get
a second source on it but we were
eventually able to get a second source
saying that Robert Muller's
investigation is looking into whether
Russian money was funneled through the
NRA to help drama is there anything that
separates the legality or illegality of
Russian money to trump through the NRA
versus all the other hypothetical
avenues that have been explored or
mentioned so far well you're right there
are a number of avenues one thing that
is pretty clear is that it is illegal to
use foreign money to influence a US
election so that if the NRA was using
Russian money in its expenditures to
help Trump which were considerable in
the 2016 election then that would pretty
clearly be illegal can you talk a little
bit about I mean I'm interested in both
the story itself but also how you work a
story like this so what is the sort of
first step in starting to source a story
like this what is the sort of work on
the ground that is done well we've been
working at the Trump Russia story since
January or before and we were the first
u.s. outlet to publish a story saying
that the connection was under
investigation Russian interference in
the election was under investigation and
that they were looking at the Trump
campaign and that eventually became
Robert Muller's investigation when he
was named special counsel later last
year
so we have been working a number of
sources to try to figure out what
exactly happened and what Muller's team
is looking at since then and so this is
a process of building you build sources
who may lead you to other sources and
you circle back to your sources and you
try to get any documentary evidence you
can it's it's a laborious time-consuming
process and McClatchy is not being the
Washington Post or the New York Times we
sometimes don't get the same kind of
leaks from on high that some of the more
prominent news organizations do but I
have to hand it to our reporters we've
got a great team with a lot of
experience and they've been dogged in
this are there long periods of time in
an investigation like this we're just
sort of nothing really happens yes you
just work on other stories during that
time or is there a lot of sort of
waiting around for sources in some sense
well I think from the reporters
standpoint there's a lot of fretting
when your sources aren't getting back to
you you haven't learned anything lately
you know what's happening so there is a
lot of sort of spreading time I call it
and I think reporters in general it's
not like you're sitting still you are
working other angles of the story you're
trying to meet people you're trying to
set up coffees you're doing this or that
in the usual reporting process from an
editor standpoint you're kind of sitting
there thinking hmm when is this going to
happen is it going to happen so there's
probably more downtime for someone like
me in an editor position than there is
for the reporters I want to start
digging into sort of the meat of the
story in a second but one more sort of
question in terms of process I it's
become very very sort of popular for
people who hear a story that they don't
necessarily like the implications of to
say hey you know it it lists anonymous
sources it's not naming the people and
it there's this sort of reflexive
tendency increasingly to
right off any story that doesn't name
sources but this misses something that's
really important which is that when you
for example say we have two sources
familiar with the matter that's very
different than saying we have an
anonymous source or we have three
sources who work within X or Y
Department the the wording of how
sources are named actually carries a lot
of weight in these types of stories can
you talk about that a little bit and the
meaning of that well it does it's always
a tricky balancing act because you want
to protect your source who you know may
be fearful of losing their job or may be
disclosing something that is
confidential or sometimes even
classified so you want to protect that
source and at the same time you want to
give the reader a little bit of
information to indicate that you're not
just you know pulling this from someone
on the street so we do try to do that
but it's um it's tricky sometimes let's
talk now about sort of the meat and the
funneling of this funding we know that
the NRA spent a lot of money in the 2016
election including 30 million dollars in
support of Donald Trump that's a lot
more than they spent in 2012 backing
Mitt Romney for example so talk to us a
little bit about the process of your
investigation and sort of the details of
how this all what was arguably put
together well yes we knew that the NRA
spent three times as much money in 2016
backing Trump as as it did in 2012
backing Mitt Romney we also knew that
there was this Russian named tortion
Alexander tortion who was a very
enthusiastic NRA supporter and came over
for some of the annual conventions the
NRA has and I mean in the process of
building the information we
learned that you know Donald Trump jr.
had been to one of the NRS conventions
and had spoken with this torsion fellow
that torsion had hosted a big delegation
of NRA officials over in Russia and it
started up a sort of Russian offshoot in
a way of the NRA called the right to
bear arms so there were there were a
number of pieces of information that we
began accumulating and it was kind of
you know it was kind of a matter of
trying to figure out whether this could
have happened and you know again we
don't know whether it happened but we do
know that it is being investigated by
the Malheur team people might hear us
talking about this and they might say
not unreasonably that it should be as
simple as just looking at the list of
the NRA s donors but as your
investigation turned up it's not quite
so simple is it well for one thing you
can't look at a list of the NRA donors
dnr a does not make its members or
donors public and the group the offshoot
that it uses to spend money in the
elections is a 501 C 4 a nonprofit that
doesn't have to disclose its donors so
yeah that is that is not that would be
great but it is not exactly how you can
get any information bigger picture what
do you see is the most likely sort of
eventual conclusion of everything that's
going on with Trump and Russia
I mean I'm hearing from people that run
the full gamut you know from impeachment
indictment all the way to this is going
to evaporate with nothing conclusive and
really no major charges from Robert
Muller you've been following this for a
long time do you have any opinion as to
what's the most likely outcome here you
know I have been following it for a long
time as has my team and I would say I
don't know what the outcome will be
you know you have a couple of people
under indictment
maybe going to trial in August or
September of this year there may be more
people cooperating that we don't know
about I think there probably are what's
it all going to boil down to is it going
to boil down to accusations about money
laundering against Trump that would have
happened probably before the election is
it going to boil down to some kind of
collusion is an illegal term but
cooperation or conspiring with Russia to
interfere in the elections is it going
to come down to obstruction of justice
you know that there are some data points
there that are you know kind of
convincing but we don't know ultimately
we know that Robert Muller has a number
of strands of his investigation he's
following we don't know which ones if
any are going to eventually result in
you know something that would be
critical of or charging the President or
if he would produce a report and that
would be sent to Congress and
impeachment proceedings may or may not
start it's ultimately still just very up
in the air what to sort of approach the
question from a slightly different angle
at this point would you be surprised if
it fizzled basically from this point
forward and nothing more really came of
it would that be a surprising outcome to
you I'd be surprised if it fizzled and
nothing more came of it yeah I would be
but but that doesn't necessarily mean
that you know Donald Trump will be the
subject of a very critical report it
could be it could be something involving
Jared Kushner or there there could be
other people who will be either charged
or the subject of a very critical report
in the end we've been speaking with
vivica Novak she is an investigative
editor for McClatchy Washington Bureau
which has been doing some excellent
excellent work thank you so much for
talking to us about this thank you it's
good to be with you